Westworld on HBO it premiered a couple
of Sundays ago season two did and for
those who tuned in to Episode two last
night I introduced to the role of major
Craddock played by our friend Jonathan
Tucker here on the Rich Eisen show how
you been brother I'm the luckiest guy in
the world happily married look at the
live in Los Angeles make a living doing
what I love to do I bust my chops but I
end up on a nice couch down here and El
Segundo California pretty good so the
Rich Eisen show I was waiting with it's
like top of the fourth list fivers yeah
you come after you come after my
enriched Ison that could be the new time
I'm for this show
Faith Family and Rich Eisen why are you
texting me a photograph of Stephon
Gilmore breaking up a pass in the AFC
Championship I'm sure like all these
guys everybody I know has got lots of
different like sports text threads yeah
and we've got the wicked the wicked
effing pissah text read from all my boys
back home down in Boston so I was going
through some stuff I was trying to find
something I saw the photo I was like God
that was a great memory for me I like
vividly remember that moment I think
it's it's exemplary of New England
sports what just been taking Buffalo
Bill and winning with them it's like
finding opportunities where other people
don't see them I think it's putting in
the sweat equity and having a payoff
when you don't know equity I think
that's New England that's that's
certainly New England
I was definitely in Boston sports so I
saw the photo I just wanted to say hey
here was a wonderful wonderful picture
you should take a look at that and know
where I come from know what we do have
you ever hurt you have you never heard
of sweat equity before now that's a good
one I've heard that that's a that's a
that's a football term I know is that
also an MMA term I think that's a
general term okay sweat equity is
something that I've heard Earvin use it
all the time Michael uses that phrase
all time got to memorize your lines put
it come and you play equity yeah are you
nervous about the sweat equity factor
for the Patriots moving forward you know
I was thinking about when I was coming
here cuz you know I am such a passionate
football fan yeah I love watching
football I'm so jealous when I see you
guys out there on giraffe that's what I
was asking in the greenroom most like
rich know you guys get to go to all
these amazing things you still find a
bit of magic here in their history tour
do and that was the answer which made me
feel
better about the world because I mean
it's the sports are so exciting football
to me is one of the great sports and and
I love the Patriots I do also start to
feel like I'm interested in like
learning more about other teams now that
we have so many champions like I love I
love I love being a patriot and I'm
always going to be supportive but I'm
excited to see what Jimmy Garoppolo is
gonna do in Stanford sure that's really
I think that's really great
okay I got a lot I got a few buddies in
Cleveland I want them to have you know I
would love to see that team I hope you
know you're saying eight and eight look
at you share in the world I'm happy we
found in the country with the cradle of
the Revolution were the beacon of
democracy the Athens of America and we
spread that we spread it through key
manifest destiny man we let America have
what we created and I think that in the
sports world we can do the same thing at
Miz standing over look at the Bruins I
mean what about them in that division
look at look at what's happening with
the Red Sox right now 16 and two I mean
it's really exciting it's exciting it's
exciting to be a New England sports fan
and I want other people to have some fun
to look at you I don't want anyone else
to have fun except that's look the
Boston sports fan is not happy unless
they're not happy though would you not
agree with that I do partially I don't
know if you guys are you friendly with
Gary Vaynerchuk at all of course I just
saw him at the draft it's the best guys
amazing and he talked about as soon as
that you know as soon as the Giants won
or as soon as the Yankees won a
championship he's like he had to find
the team that made him unhappy he's he
wants to own the jeff course and of
course the easiest way to own the Jets
is to not fly on you know private jets
you fly commercially you can buy the
actual Jets you know not blame that's
what he always talks about which i think
is a great life lesson but I love the
idea that he's like out there rooting
for the team that doesn't win and I love
beating the Jets and helping him
preserve his his Jets about eight
percent Wow yeah so I'm happy to like
look at some other teams right now you
[Laughter]
[Music]
know
I only want Jimmy G to do well because
he should be the QB and waiting in New
England
well the QB and waiting is gonna have to
come and at some point Tom Brady's not
walking through that door to use a
Boston sports vernacular and who is that
is it a it's not Brian Hoyer and Danny
Etling is gonna have to start coming up
from his LSU roots the seventh rounder
right now who's not gonna be I mean when
you what do you got I have no idea
it's got he's still in college now
apparently I mean I with all due respect
Danny Etling it's not gonna be him who
knows wasn't I mean Brady went from
$1.99 to the next one by the way we had
a great Mariucci was on our show last
Friday on our radio only show and just
giving him grief about drafting Giovanni
Carr mozzie over Tom Brady it's just
it's it's it's one of those draft
moments and that's another thing about
the draft that I love too we don't know
right now what just happened over the
weekend right well y-you see that could
be the next moment there that that's
part of just football fandom yeah and I
love like how these players respond to
what number they might be what their
expectations were verse what actually
ends up happening when you know nine
teams ahead of you pick somebody nine
they're nine teams pick somebody else
ahead of you right and your response is
well nine foot nine teams made a mistake
I mean that's the sort of like mental
conditioning when you look at like what
what people talk about in terms of
support psychology you watch
what's-his-name show here on AT&T the is
it undeniable though I mean that's the
Joe Buck show is absolutely magnificent
it's a great show cuz they talked about
how do you deal with not being you know
selected first second third four is
always an amazing story like that I want
to take a 60-second break come back talk
some Westworld and I know you're a deep
big-time MMA fan based on your work
right here on audience from the special
show kingdom and I'm also Rahman you
wanted me to do this I'll do this the
two places that I'm hearing the NFL yes
I only want to hear this man maybe you
guys can influence the vote there's two
places that the NFL I think it's down to
two spots when the next NFL Draft gonna
be Jonathan Tucker is here so should you
and we'll take your phone calls before
the show is done at 8:40 for 204 rich
back with
West world's Jonathan Tucker in 60
seconds
we're back here with Jonathan Tucker at
Jonathan mtucker on Twitter I follow him
you should too
westward a West world of course I've got
sports on the brain it's not Westwood
although that would be an interesting
show
wouldn't it be if well just that you
would be able to go into some sort of
fantasy world where you become a
basketball player or something virtual
reality glasses you're a football Josh
Rosen could be a star of Westwood
exactly right you just made a Josh Rosen
reference any Westworld on HBO 9:00 p.m.
Eastern Time when you get an offer to
say hey how'd you like to join West
world what does that like Frank I mean
it's a the the quality of storytelling
led really by by this magical married
pair Jonah Nolan and his wife Lisa joy I
mean it's just thrilling it's it's it's
you don't you you watch these shows
you're a fan of the show right you're a
fan of these storytellers and when they
ask you to come and collaborate it's
very gratifying I don't know it's just
very gratifying and so I mean when
you're when you're reading how many
times you have to read the script to
understand what the hell is going on oh
yes usually like usually about 90
seconds because they only send you your
stuff everything else is blacked out so
you're reading like a CIA scripts are
redacted yeah yeah you get just your
stuff you have no idea so what's really
fun is you go to the premiere and you're
you know you're out there on the red
carpet and you're taking all these
photos he's like oh so retro you you're
you're an actor I love you are you on
the show I am at the aisle fantastic oh
you what episodes you in not sure I
think four and five but I don't know
great what world I don't know we were
yes so it's there's a lot of mystery so
I'm watching the show with the same
sense of excitement and curiosity is you
guys well we were genuinely excited to
see you last night because in all
honesty to continue this we were under
the impression that you might be you
would coming on the show well we might
not be able to talk about the fact that
you were sure yeah cuz you wouldn't know
if I'm gonna be up in the episode and
they're fanatic I mean this is the firth
at clip is the first clip that I've seen
outside of the actual show itself
because they just don't release photos
so your DVR or watching this lob just
like what the hell is going very
democratic I like it
Wow I will tell you - in terms of like
the environment that we're in with
having a conversation about diversity in
the entertainment business this is one
of the most diverse sets and not just
the cast but the crew from the writers
room down and it really I feel like it
does strengthen the storytelling and and
the creative process that we have there
all these different perspectives
different backgrounds coming together
you get a richer stronger story and
particularly with the with the way in
which West worlds were in toggles
between different worlds and also
different times it's helpful to have
that team really keeping it all together
I was so impressed by that well we're
excited to have Jeffrey Wright from the
show here on Wednesday I've known James
Marsden for a while he said I mean I
think he's in like ten fantasy leagues
it's insane how many football he's only
the funniest people I've ever spent time
around he is a riot I mean he is so
funny I had talked fantasy football I
hadn't know I had yeah I mean he's he's
nuts about that
Jonathan Tucker here on the Rich Eisen
show and you know we we first met
through Kingdom when you were coming
here a few years ago to promote that
when I saw Conor McGregor throw a dolly
at a bus I thought that was that would
have been something ripped straight from
yeah and what Jay Kulina would have
absolutely gone full Conor McGregor my
wild character Jake absolutely I thought
to myself that's straight yeah and I say
you know I was so disappointed Conor
McGregor fan I've gotten to meet him
I've been to two or three of his fights
including the Mayweather fight I've
trained it as gym in Dublin I'm a huge
Conor McGregor fan and what he's done
for the sport has been remarkable and
he's a really good dude so I don't know
exactly what happened that evening in
Madison Square Garden was comparable for
a lot of those fighters well some think
it was totally staged right well I know
for you know I mean as factually as I
know the USC was not happy about this
top down and Dana runs a really tight
ship and he's a really transparent human
being I've spoken with him about lots of
subjects and I've been deeply impressed
by his character a true truly I mean
truly is he gives it to you like he like
you seized it and feels it and it didn't
sound like he was pleased with this and
dick I will say Conor McGregor did set
up maybe one of the biggest but the
highest revenue fights that we'll ever
see in the UFC with khabib I mean it'll
be Conor McGregor vs. Russia and that is
something I would pay $199 to pay per
view against the entire row ukyo yeah
that's rocky for i can see the posters
now and if that's why everybody thinks
that it was staged well I mean I think I
don't think Conor McGregor's brilliant I
mean he's a he's just top to bottom he's
not just one of the best you know
fighters and talkers out there but you
know from the clothing that he wears to
you know his social media handling the
way he set up fights the way he's he's
run his business has been I mean it's
been brilliant but uh and I think that
he'll end up having set up one of the
greatest UFC fights in the history of
that League and certainly the biggest in
MMA what did you learn about MMA
fighters doing we're not here long
enough I I started thinking that MMA and
the UFC was the worst thing for America
that it was a terrible sport for sports
blows [ __ ] fighting for human beings you
love boxing so much or I like boxing
sure yeah I would always be like I'm the
boxing guy you know these people you
meet at a dinner party it's like I don't
like him and I'm gonna BA I like boxing
right and now I but I realized I just
didn't know I didn't know what I was
talking about the sacrifice these guys
give up their understanding of martial
arts it's really martial arts you're
combining Brazilian jiu-jitsu and
greco-roman wrestling and boxing okay by
the stem of the MA it's mixed martial
arts so these are coming out of the
tradition of where you want to send your
son and daughter to go and learn about
respect and humility and self-defense
and like that's okay in a dojo of karate
but apparently like in a cage it's
disgusting and and bloodsport and I just
fundamentally have learned that's not
that's not true and my perspective was
wrong well I think you could speak to
this too Chris is that the number of
guests that we've had from the MMA
fighters turn media members or media
members or just fighters that we've had
they've all been spectacular guests with
just tremendous great heads on their
shoulders and hearts oh he's all of them
almost won every single
and and kind and gentle they're the kind
of people like you know we have a little
guest room in our house and I tend to
lend it out frequently you guys are all
welcome to come over the corner Corner
corner corner and and I had we've had my
wife basically said the only people I
really enjoy having at her house now in
terms of like their manners and the way
in which they like take care of
everything or fighters they're like that
you know everything's clean they leave a
little note they want to open the door
for her they want to like cook food
bring stuff they're like the most
generous kind people and so I guess this
is my advertisement for like how's the
house get fighters make great house
guests is what I want to ultimately say
I've come to learn so much about the
sport and the people behind who are part
of it and I have been nothing but
impressed over and over and over
Jonathan Tucker here on the Rich Eisen
show all right you want the information
that I had you've been after me the
whole show and I yeah okay yeah the NFL
Draft was just in Dallas after being in
Philadelphia we're going next well
there's a it's now like Super Bowl
bidding right Vegas is in the mix we had
brent musburger on a couple weeks ago
saying that Fremont Street would be the
spot Vegas in the mix for next year well
this is what yes these these have been
all been bidding came in Ohio but I
don't think it's gonna go to Canton
until they've totally remodeled the
whole area I know that they're still
constructing the new facilities there
and new hotel there Los Angeles is in
the mix but I don't think they're gonna
have it until there's the new stadium
for everyone to see as opposed to a hole
in the ground
so that leaves two spots that are in
this spot Kansas City and Tennessee oh
honey moon diddle Tennessee all right
the sweet grass of Nashville I think
that's oh yeah that my from what I heard
a lot of the talk that's the
front-runner I love both from cities I
spent time about the city's great
barbecue there and Kansas City great
barbecue in Nashville Tennessee both
spots I honeymooned in Tennessee so I
gotta say I I would vote for for there
now I what about location I don't know
the answer to that okay I don't know the
answer to where it would be but all I
know is that when I went to Nashville
the last time I I fancy myself a really
karaoke singer really really good I can
see an outstanding karaoke singer I mean
I'll tear a spot down with Sinatra
tomorrow hashtag buy Sinatra I will
destroy any place a microphone in it's
over that's really these guys will test
they will testify to that they've seen
it multiple times like they're already
there okay so I put my name rip the mic
away from all people we've heard it
Steve Hutchinson has been spreading that
rumor and it's false
hashtag fake news stop it reason why I
bring this up is this last time was a
Thursday night game in Nashville we show
up Wednesday night and I'm going out
there or the friend of mine was Kara
Henderson Sneed who also likes to
institute karaoke we put our names and
we'll automatically 10th on the list
like damn we gotta wait and then we're
thinking well I guess we'll wait or we
might just leave and then the next
person after the next person if Vanessa
won It was as if American Idol had just
busted out one person has lost Valentin
the stakes were rising with every night
every new song it was it was with every
new it was a people were handing out
their their CDs to people when they
coming off the stage I'm like what have
you do I crushed it question I did
that's what you did your Sinatra's
Universal you're a winner to the point
where I need to spread the spread of the
wings I need to spread the news spread
the winning family rich accent that's it
that's it good to see you John you are
the man Jonathan
Tucker check out West world every Sunday
night on HBO he has no idea when he's
going to be on all of it here's
definitely not what's redacted his
Sunday night at 9:00 period the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience